hayden panettiere went from star on the
rise to overnight sensation with the
release of nbc superhero series heroes
in 2006. panittierra portrayed claire
bennett a superpowered high school
cheerleader whose survival held the key
to saving the world save the cheerleader
save the world upon release heroes
became an unexpected smash hit that
instantly put hayden panettiere at the
forefront of the pop culture world
before heroes panitiere had already made
a bit of a name for herself with
memorable turns on ally mcbeal malcolm
in the middle and as the co-star of
disney's ice princess but the runaway
success of heroes seemed to put her on
the path to legit super stardom
panettiere promptly began booking
projects to help her get a foothold in
the film world unfortunately one of
those films wound up stalling out hayden
panettiere's film career before it ever
really began i love you beth cooper was
one of many teen comedies that came out
in the mid-2000s hoping to ride the
coattails of the massive 2007 hit
superbat after superbad helped put emma
stone jonah hill and michael cera on
hollywood's a-list of teen talent one
could hardly blame hayden panettiere for
hoping for a similar big screen breakout
much like superbad i love you beth
cooper took a night in the life approach
to teen debauchery the film followed its
teen ensemble as they searched for love
and lust on the evening of their high
school graduation unfortunately while
beth cooper clearly aspired to achieve
the same successful mix of ranch at
heart super bad it never came close to
hitting its goal barely crossing the 15
million mark at the box office many
reviewers faulted lackluster work from
director chris columbus but they also
agreed that the film's cast didn't bring
much to the table mark olson of the los
angeles times called the film a flat
tired rehash of teen movie story tropes
meanwhile timeout's anna smith said it
paled in comparison to similar films
like superbad and noted the pace is slow
and lines fall flat
overall critics found the film to be a
lifeless affair that falters on both the
comedic and romantic fronts
wow
thanks unfortunately for hayden
panettiere her face was all over the
movie's promotional materials and her
career on the big screen never really
recovered after i love you beth cooper
flopped at the box office and with
critics panettiere's career faltered
losing most of the momentum she gained
with heroes future film projects never
earned her the a-list status it seemed
she'd been on track to achieve in the
2011 film the forger panettiere played a
teenager who begins a relationship with
a young art forger played by josh
hutcherson and despite an impressive
ensemble cast that included oscar
winners viola davis and ellen burstin
2016's custody didn't fare much better
in the film panettiere played ally
fisher a young lawyer who takes on a
difficult custody case representing a
troubled single mother also in 2011
panettiere joined the scream franchise
as teenager kirby reed for scream four
in the film kirby gets wrapped up in the
latest round of brutal killings that
rock the otherwise sleepy town of
woodsboro california although she was
seriously wounded during the film's
terrifying climax kirby's ultimate fate
was open-ended leaving the door open for
her to possibly return to the franchise
however while many other former scream
stars are indeed set to return in 2022's
fifth installment titled simply scream
panettiere has not yet been confirmed to
be among them aside from the
adrenaline-fueled scream 4 most of
panatire's post beth cooper feature
projects have been relatively low-key
affairs however although her film career
never really took off panettiere did
find success again on the small screen
the nighttime soap nashville ran for six
seasons first on abc before moving to
cmt with panettiere co-starring his
up-and-coming country starlet julia
farns her performance was well received
by critics and earned her two golden
globe nominations so while hayden
panettiere may not be the a-list movie
star that heroes fans thought she'd
become she's still doing pretty well for
herself
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]